bonjour bonjour monsieur le président
bonjour à vous je ne vois pas tout le
monde chez vous et bonjour à tout le
monde
merci alors nous sommes en présence de
Madame Pinera horte sénateur de
sénatrice de Guyane madame
Vivette Lopez c'est la prise du Gard et
Madame Marie merci
de Saône-et-Loire et michine Jack c'est
notre Saint-Barthélemy
bonjour mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
[Musique]
nous allons débuter le propos donc mes
chers collègues je dois excuser le
président Artano qui est actuellement à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon et qui nous
suit sur le site du Sénat qui diffuse la
présente audition la délégation
sénatorielle aux outre-mer en ton ce
matin monsieur Benissa Housseini
président du conseil départemental de
Mayotte dans le cadre de la préparation
de son rapport sur l'évolution
institutionnelle des Outre-mer nous vous
remercions vivement monsieur le
Président pour votre disponibilité nous
sommes en train d'achever notre cycle
d'audition qui nous a permis de
consulter les exécutifs de
Saint-Barthélémy la Réunion
wallis-et-futunes Saint-Martin
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon la Polynésie
française et la Guyane cette semaine
concernant Mayotte on évoque souvent une
départementalisation inachevée au
progressive qui nourrit de nombreuses
interrogations voire déception
la connexion n'est pas très bonne je
crois parce que vous entend par
intermittence là par moment ça bloque
j'ai essayé de parler un peu plus
lentement
vous me direz donc concernant Mayotte
on évoque souvent une
départementalisation
je sais pas qu'est-ce qui se passe
je sais pas pourquoi ça
ici on vous entend très très bien
non ça passe pas du tout madame
excusez-moi
[Musique]
non c'est pas ça
c'est la connexion
[Musique]
alors monsieur le Président vous nous
entendez alors ce que je vous
ce que je vous propose comme vous avez
le questionnaire et que nous vous
entendons très très bien je vous propose
de prendre la parole et de répondre aux
différentes questions qui vous ont été
adressées
[Musique]
oui donc vous nous entendez oui nous
vous entendons parfaitement donc
je vous propose si vous le voulez bien
si vous avez les questions sous les yeux
de prendre la parole et de répondre aux
questions puisque nous vous entendons
très bien
bonjour
merci donc je prends la première
question le bilan de l'organisation
institutionnelle de Mayotte d'abord
c'est précisé que nous nous inscrivons
pas forcément dans la même logique
d'organisation institutionnelle que les
autres collectivités uniques qui va
retenir que
Ethan nous on a été érigé en
collectivité unique mais nous estimons
que
on n'est pas allé jusqu'au bout de cette
nouvelle compétence cette nouvelle
organisation qui nous a été
accordé
par d'abord référendum en 2009 et mis en
place
2000 à 2011 ou Mayotte est devenu
collectivité unique à double compétences
on a l'impression chez nous que ces
compétences là cette organisation c'est
limité de prendre en compte le côté
départemental
de cette nouvelle organisation et pas
suffisamment le côté régional et c'est
ce qu'aujourd'hui d'abord les gens
déplorent on oublie que nous sommes une
collectivité unique à double compétences
et qu'il faut que les deux compétences
puissent pleinement
être mis mis en place
même si
même si tout ne peut pas être mise en
place tout d'un coup mais nous n'avons
pas nous n'avons pas encore pris le
compétences par exemple des routes les
collèges les lycées mais même en matière
de développement économique où nous
commençons à travailler sur leur domaine
de formation là aussi c'est compétences
là
régionales n'ont pas été forcément mis
complètement en place donc c'est un
bilan plutôt
pas suffisant même s'il y a eu des
avancées mais nous estimons que ce n'est
pas suffisant et il est demandé ici nous
demandons d'aller beaucoup plus loin
dans ces mises en place de cette
nouvelle organisation que Mayotte vit
depuis 2011
oui oui nous vous
voilà
par contre oui
allez-y poursuivez
et puis effectivement
et c'est là aussi si on se refera ça
à l'appel de Fort-de-France
effectivement nous militons aussi pour
la mise en place d'une politique
publique beaucoup plus adaptée à nos
territoires vous savez très très
récemment on nous avait consulté pour un
loi programme en Mayotte
et les élus s'étaient positionnés pour
rien la vie défavorable parce que nous
estimons que le contenu les règles qui
étaient mis en place n'était pas
forcément adapté à la réalité à la
réalité mahoraise peut-être qu'ils sont
adaptés à la réalité au contexte
national mais au niveau du territoire du
département de Mayotte c'est extra ne
faut pas forcément adapter je parle de
problématique liées
au droit du sol c'est un problématique
nationale nous demandons que pour
Mayotte on a beaucoup plus loin que ce
qui aiment bien parce que vous savez
très bien qu'aujourd'hui à Mayotte le
nombre de personnes en situation
irrégulière en tout cas d'étrangers ou
même titre de ce jour
qui elle par massivement vers la
métropole vers la Réunion vers les
autres les autres régions et remplacés
par d'autres
qui arrivent donc il va falloir nous le
réclamons de tête que le texte puisse
être adapté à cette à cette
en difficulté
par ailleurs sur d'autres textes on
estime que
il est adapté chez nous mais d'une
manière aussi incompréhensible parce que
il ne répond pas ce ne sont pas
problématiques liées sur par exemple je
vous donne cette règle de carence qui
est imposée aux personnes en situation
d'handicap
sur le territoire qui ne répond pas
forcément à notre réalité locale ou à la
demande à la demande locale
je vous remercie mais nous vivons aussi
par exemple sur la partie de contrôle
des frontières aujourd'hui ça ça délit
ça s'élimine
monsieur le Président
qui n'est valable que à Mayotte et qui
n'est pas venu ni connu dans les autres
territoires donc il y a tous ces
problèmes là où nous considérons que le
fait ne sont pas suffisamment
soit adapté d'une manière
pas suffisante ou pas satisfaisante du
tout
nous avons quelques petits soucis
parfois
la communication se coupe par
intermittence mais nous avons compris le
la globalité de votre propos
pardon je vous dis je vous disais que
nous avons eu quelques coupures par
intermittence mais que nous avons
compris la globalité de votre propos
c'est compliqué
je ne vous entends pas du tout je sais
pas qu'est-ce qui se passe
la connexion est
je vous propose de poursuivre oui
[Musique]
oui
nous vous proposons de poursuivre
en suivant le fil des questions
c'est quoi la question
oui
[Musique]
aitement
oui donc les questions suivantes c'était
attendez
donc
voilà
on a changé
[Musique]
allô
oui je vous entends maintenant vous
entend c'est très bien
là on a changé de connexion
allons-y alors
avez-vous des exemples d'action de
stratégie ou de projets entravés ou
bloqués par l'organisation
institutionnelle et normative actuelle
oui ce sont ce que je ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure c'est par rapport à
encore une fois le problème magnétique à
l'immigration clandestine je vais
énormément insister aujourd'hui la loi
du sol tel qu'il est utilisée
aujourd'hui bloque aujourd'hui
clairement la situation Mayotte puisque
et aussi le projet du
comment le visa territorialisé donc on a
un certain nombre d'étrangers qui sont
Mayotte qu'on ne peut pas on ne peut pas
forcément
on ne peut pas le faire voyager ils ont
ils ont été régularisés mais il reste à
Mayotte et voilà et ils sont bloqués là
parce que on leur a mis en place un
système de visa territorialisé après moi
je voulais aller un peu plus loin pour
ne pas parler que de l'immigration que
la déclinestine et là je rejoins un
petit peu les autres sans forcément
demander un changement de statut
institutionnel de Mayotte c'est que
permettre peut-être un peu plus à
Mayotte de pouvoir un peu plus coopérer
avec nos amis de la région nous nous
voilà nos voisins directs je parle de
Madagascar je parle de de de
Tanzanie et autres puisque comme vous le
savez nous avons une facilité d'échange
avec ces gens-là on peut travailler
beaucoup plus facilement avec eux parce
que on a des liens un peu plus proche ou
fraternel avec eux et que si on pouvait
permettre aux régions de pouvoir
beaucoup plus traiter directement avec
ces régions là nos vois certains de nos
voisins je crois que ça ça faciliterait
pas mal la coopération régionale chez
nous parce qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
signer de convention avec ces
territoires là il faut passer par eux
par Paris et bon c'est c'est Sarah les
choses peut-être un peu plus compliqué
mais je crois que si effectivement on
nous donnait un peu plus de l'argent ça
ce niveau là ça pourrait
pas mal pas mal aidé mais permettez-moi
d'insister énormément
sur la partie émigration et la partie
étrangers à Mayotte
merci
après la question suite et vous
exercez des compétences dans de nouveaux
domaines notamment
des compétences
moi je pour la question numéro 3 moi je
demande surtout qu'on aille jusqu'au
bout d'abord de la situation actuelle
sur les compétences que nous sommes
censées exercer aujourd'hui où on n'a
pas encore on n'est pas encore aller
jusqu'au bout avant de demander d'autres
d'autres
compétences aujourd'hui clairement le
cas de Mayotte sur la compétence
régionale très peu a été a été fait au
départ on n'est même pas à 50% de
compétences régionales exercées donc moi
ce que je demande c'est qu'aujourd'hui
on aille d'abord au bout de ses
compétences là que Mayotte puisse
pleinement exercer ses compétences
régionales avant d'aller ailleurs vous
nous demandez la question est-ce que à
l'inverse nous avons des compétences à
vouloir restituer
à l'état
si les compensations sont fait
correctement nous ne sommes pas
forcément demandeurs de de
restituer des compétences qui se passent
aujourd'hui notamment en matière de
continuité territoire réelle entre
autres ou nous exerçons des compétences
nous avons toutes les compétences mais
de continuer voilà que nous exerçons
mais derrière l'état nous nous
accompagne pas alors que nous
considérons que là l'état tout son à
tout son devoir à faire quand je prends
la ligne entre Corse et
le continent être compétences de interne
de mobilité continuité territoriale il
est plein exercé par l'État chez nous
entre la petite air et la grandeur
la liaison et à la charge entière du
du de notre collectivité
sans aucune participation de l'État donc
ce que nous demandons c'est que on
puisse aller jusqu'au bout
de cette compétence régionale et que
l'État accompagne correctement comme sur
ce doigt dans l'égalité avec les autres
territoires
parce que là aussi nous nous sentons un
peu lésés je prends des exemples très
simples dans les autres territoires
c'est EDF d'électricité qui gère nous en
maillotonné encore dans un système local
on a en matière aérienne Air France qui
ne desserre pas Mayotte alors qu'il
dessert tous les autres territoires donc
en matière là de continuité territoriale
il y a énormément à faire et c'est
effectivement l'État doit jouer son rôle
pleinement on considère camaïeu tous les
temps ne joue pas suffisamment son rôle
nous n'avons pas forcément de
compétences particulières à restituer
nous demandons que les choses soient mis
en place correctement d'une manière
équitable et cohérent
donc
quels appréciation portez-vous sur la
prise en compte des spécificités et des
sucres
oui sur la question numéro 4 nous encore
une fois
nous ne demandons pas d'aller sur
l'article 73 de la Constitution on est
bien dans l'artiste 74 mais néanmoins
nous demandons effectivement par moment
que les textes puissent être légèrement
adaptés à notre situation à nos
contextes local qui n'est pas forcément
les mêmes réalités que la métropole je
donne des exemples lorsque à Mayotte on
parle de 10 000 mineurs isolés entre
8000 et 10000 isolés
pour le national c'est pas grand chose
au Mayotte 374
km²
299.000 habitants 10000 constituent un
nombre très très très important et je
crois que lorsqu'on traite ce sujet là
faut pas le traiter pareil au niveau
national que que chez nous et que par
moment ce texte-là doivent être un peu
adapté c'est décrire là doivent être un
peu adaptés ou ces lois par rapport à
notre réalité des différentes
territoires
estimez-vous que vous n'êtes pas assez
consulté lors de l'élaboration des lois
et des décrets pour avis sur
ces deux éléments c'est d'abord on n'est
pas suffisamment et consulter et puis
c'est très rare que notre avis la vie du
conseil départemental en tout cas de
Mayotte soit tenu après par moments on
est consulté mais on a l'impression
qu'on est juste consulté pour la forme
mais on va pas après sur le fond de nos
remarques de nos observations lorsqu'ils
sont lorsqu'elles sont elles sont
données donc non seulement on souhaite
être consulté mais surtout que les avis
que nous donnons puis cette prise
en considération c'est pas suffisamment
consulté et pas suffisamment retenu
pensez-vous que la procédure d'urgence
doit être améliorée les délais de
réponse puisqu'il était bon cette
question est remontée lors des autres
auditions et il s'avère que souvent les
délais de consultation sont relativement
courts pour permettre une réponse
bien sûr c'est ce que nous remarquons
tous d'ailleurs plusieurs fois nous
avons notamment lorsqu'on a été
sollicités sur le projet loi Mayotte on
avait demandé justement que les délais
puissent rallonger parce que le temps
est parti vu l'épaisseur du du dossier
vu le nombre de sujets qui étaient
dedans que le délai puisse être rallongé
afin de nous permettre de faire un
travail approfondi et là aussi on ne
s'en a pas été on n'a pas Eugène cause
donc effectivement les délais qui sont
donnés sont souvent très très courts et
qui ne laisse pas suffisamment de temps
pour travailler sur le sujet et il est
important effectivement de rallonger un
peu de trouver
solutions intermédiaire alternative
oui
au principe d'identité législative sauf
dans certains domaines un passage au
principe de spécialité législatives sur
serait-il souhaitable dans notre domaine
selon vous
mais c'est la demande que je veux dire
c'est que
lorsque il doit évoluer oui nous avons
demandé à être département d'être une
région oui les lois doivent s'appliquer
par partout mais comme je le dis tout à
l'heure de temps en temps prendre du
compte un peu de notre effectivement
notre
identité
et par moments
particulières et par moments de légères
adaptations nous demandons pas d'être
complètement traité différemment parce
que comme je le dis nous on était dans
l'article 73 et on a voulu basculer sur
le 74 nous demande pas forcément que
tout doit
tout doit être adapté mais juste par
moment tenir compte un peu de cette
spécificité
locale notamment je le dis je le redis
encore en matière notamment du droit de
sol la matière de coopération ce sont
des domaines je crois que on peut on
peut un peu ajuster je parle ajuster le
texte par rapport à notre réalité
qu'elle appréciation portez-vous sur les
mécanismes qui permettent
en application du troisième et quatrième
alinéade de l'article 73 constitution de
solliciter les habilitations à adapter
les normes dans les domaines de
compétences de l'État selon vous
sont-ils fonctionnels
sur les Spurs les mécanismes permettant
de 3e
attendez deux secondes
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on peut continuer on reviendra
sur ce sujet là après parce que j'ai pas
envie de
donc la place reconnue du statut civil
de loi locale est-elle satisfaisante
selon vous
moi je ne cherche pas forcément d'une
application du droit local bon ça a été
appliqué pendant quelques temps local on
a demandé à être dans le droit commun je
ne cherche pas forcément revenir sur sur
un local spécifique ça c'est une demande
peut-être des autorita mais ce n'est pas
forcément
c'est pas forcément une demande pour
Mayotte
l'organisation des institutions et les
règles de fonctionnement du conseil
départemental de Mayotte sont-elles
satisfaisantes bon vous avez en partie
répondu avez-vous relevé des points de
blocage des dysfonctionnements ou des
problèmes d'interprétation des textes
donc
les institutions
non les règles du Conseil du
fonctionnement du conseil départemental
je crois que c'est les mêmes règles à
peu près que dans les autres territoires
je dis tout simplement encore une fois à
ce niveau là on n'est pas allé jusqu'au
bout là aussi de leur demande parce que
vous savez comme je le dis on a une
collectivité unique aujourd'hui on est
Mayotte 260 pratiquement 300000
habitants on est sur 26 élus alors que
dans d'autres collectivités avec le même
nombre d'habitants il dépense de 51 de
nuit voilà le vrai problème de situation
qui fait que les élus Maoris sont
pratiquement saturés en termes de
comment en termes de de charge de charge
de travail de commission qui doivent
porter des délégations extérieures qui
doivent porter là il y a effectivement
réellement à améliorer c'est une
revendication ancienne c'est vers les 51
de lui je donne tout le temps ces
exemples là la Corrèze le département
avec une seule compétence département
210000 habitants ils sont à 43 élus la
Guyane ils sont à 52 élus avec le nombre
d'habitants d'ailleurs nous venons
dépasser la Guyane un nombre d'habitants
et si aujourd'hui nous sommes encore
à 26 élus ça ça forme un vrai un vrai
situation de de blocage de
dysfonctionnement parce que on n'arrive
pas à forcement être partout partout à
la fois par contre des problèmes liés à
l'interprétation des textes pas
forcément puisque comme je le dis c'est
une revendication nous demandons pas
être forcément mieux traiter que les
autres nous demandons à être traité au
moins pareil que les autres nous avons
des soucis un peu partout en matière de
dotation on n'est pas aligné sur les
autres nous sommes aujourd'hui Mayotte à
135 euros de DGF par habitant
125 euros de DGF par habitant qu'à la
Réunion il y a 245 donc vous voyez bien
le décalage qu'il y a c'est ce problème
là qui aujourd'hui cause énormément de
problèmes de mise en place de
l'organisation
correct et puis voilà donc
vous êtes en précisé qu'est-ce qui
justifie ce changement de cette
différence de DGF par habitant
on sait pas
forcément nous sommes nous l'avons
demandé ce n'est pas on n'a jamais de
réponse et lorsque il y a des
progressions c'est des progressions très
très très faibles c'est juste peut-être
une ajustement par rapport à l'inflation
par rapport à ces choses-là mais jamais
un vrai débat sur ce sujet là qui
permettrait d'évoluer vers une égalité
pour rebondir avez-vous des études
statistiques justement sur le coût de la
vie l'évolution
économique de Mayotte parce que souvent
on dit que c'est statistiques font des
faux
je peux pas vous le donner là tout de
suite mais ce que je vais vous dire
c'est que
on a ces éléments là
mais il y a ils ne sont pas forcément
prisés en considération les la
démographie on a des éléments de la
démographie que tout le monde conteste
que tout le monde dit voilà qui ne
répond pas forcément à la réalité après
on a tous tout le temps tendance lorsque
nous sort ces chiffres là à nous
comparer avec ce qui se passe dans nos
voisins directs dans 10 ans oui oui vous
êtes à 9000 9000 euros par de PIB par
habitant quand
comment quand les Comores ils sont à
4000 ou quand Madagascar ils sont à 3000
mais on ne sort jamais le chiffre de la
Réunion qui sont en cours 24000 quelque
chose comme ça qui sont beaucoup plus
loin que nous donc on a des données je
crois que les données existent
mais après chacun les utilisent comme
au milieu
ils ne sont pas pris contre un niveau
plus national nous nous demandons plus
un aliment vernational on a tendance à
vouloir nous mettre dans le paquet avec
la région directement mais voilà c'est
Mayotte aujourd'hui ce qui fait deux
maillots aujourd'hui le territoire
européen le plus pauvre parce que voilà
on veut nous comparer plus avec notre la
région que avec le National
alors comment jugez-vous le rôle de et
l'accompagnement de l'État pour exercer
vos compétences
[Musique]
beaucoup trop présent dans le
fonctionnement des collectivités d'une
manière générale on parle au conseil
départemental simplement mais mais dans
les collectivités on aurait aimé que
l'État laisse
plus les collectivités à exercer
pleinement leur compétences et faire le
et l'État faire son rôle de contrôle de
l'égalité
pour quelle raison l'avant projet de loi
présenté au début du 2022 a-t-il été
rejeté
nous avons nous avons jugé que le
il n'est pas allé suffisamment loin
vous savez avant que le projet va
Mayotte a été proposé il y a eu des
assises qui ont été mis en place des
tables ronds il y a tout un travail qui
a été demandé à Mayotte qui a fait plus
de 200 propositions
et lorsqu'il est revenu chez nous on
nous envoie un texte définitif
c'est-à-dire que entre les propositions
qui a été faite il y a pas eu d'échanges
mais on a consulté le territoire
l'État a pris le gouvernement a tranché
et nous envoyer un texte définitif qui
n'est pas les suffisamment loin sur la
demande de maori je donne des exemples
sur cette convergence de droit sur cette
égalité sociale dans revendiquées par
les Maoris
on ne retrouve pas suffisamment
d'avancer dedans et surtout on n'a pas
eu cette échéance demandé par les
baouais sur cette convergence de droit à
l'horizon de quelle année
Mayotte allait-il être aligné au
National au niveau de Galilée des
égalités de cette conversion de droit
tous les droits je ne parle pas
forcément les droits sociaux de tous les
droits y compris le DGF que je vous ai
dit tout à l'heure à quel quel horizon a
l'ONU être aligné cette réponse là n'a
pas cette question là pas cette question
n'a pas eu de réponse donc la première
chose c'est de ça nous avons demandé
toujours en matière en matière de en
matière sociale que les communes
puissent être consultées avant les
émissions de titre de séjour on les
retrouve pas forcément de tests vous
savez la revendication première démarrer
c'est cette convergence de droit on
n'est pas il y a eu des avancées on ne
peut pas dire qu'il n'y a pas eu
d'avancer il y a pas eu il y a eu des
avancées mais nous estimons que nous
sommes restés à peu près à 30% de
revendications des marées à la matière
donc nous on aurait aimé que qu'on aille
beaucoup plus loin sur ce sujet là mais
pas que sur sur convergence de droit je
vous parle aussi des
parce que problématique liées comme je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure de nos
compétences régionales
ne problématique de la réforme du mode
de Skoda nous demandons à être alignés
comme les autres collectivités uniques
un mode de service scrutin par liste
avec une révision du nombre de
d'élus bon il y a aussi il y a un effort
nous sommes passés de 26 à 41 quand nous
on revendiquait 52 donc il y a eu des
avancées mais qu'on ne juge pas
suffisant et puis comme je le dis tout à
l'heure vous savez le test est arrivé
chez nous en décembre fin de l'année il
fallait nous prononcer donc je crois que
si je me trompe pas il est arrivé chez
nous le 17 décembre on avait très peu de
temps pour travailler dessus et surtout
on n'avait pas la possibilité de
discuter d'échanger de négocier avec les
services de l'État pour aboutir à un
texte qui fait consensus mais il nous
fallait nous prononcer sur ce texte là
rien que sur ce texte là que bien sûr
nous juge pas suffisant
je crois que si à un moment il y avait
eu un temps de travail ou
s'il y avait eu
une comment on appelle ça une
organisation une instance de travail qui
permet de travailler sur ce sujet-là on
se serait sorti avec un consensus un
projet commun mais malheureusement ça
n'a pas été mis en place et il fallait
simplement se prononcer oui ou non sur
un texte qui n'était pas voilà par
contre nous sommes aujourd'hui que je
demandeur d'un projet de loi Mayotte qui
sera travaillé pleinement avec des
propositions qui reprendraient les
propositions qui ont été faites par les
Mahorais
quel quel est votre avis sur une
éventuelle fusion ou réécriture des
articles 73 et 74 de la Constitution
ouvre en droit à des statues sur mesure
et à la fin de la dichotomie d'homme
comme tout en laissant évidemment au
territoire de satisfait de leur statut
actuel la faculté de les conserver et
selon vous quelle garde fou devrait y
figurer compte tenu de votre vision de
l'avenir institutionnel de Mayotte
nous on s'inscrit pas dans cette logique
là on entend le débat porté par nos amis
mais les amis ultramarins certains qui
aimaient nous on s'inscrit pas dans ce
dans ce déballage de révision de la
Constitution sur ces deux articles là je
crois que l'article 73 à sa place
l'article 74 à sa place il faut juste
par moment des ajustements des textes
des lois des petites ajustements au
territoire même si on est sur l'article
60 74
des ajustements qui par moments et
permettent un peu plus de
d'autonomie donc je parle pas
d'autonomie de possibilités au
territoire de travailler voilà plus
sereinement c'est tout ce que nous nous
demandons c'est que il y a des
spécificités pour les territoires les
Mayotte aujourd'hui est une collectivité
unique
nous nous inscrivons pleinement sur
cette ligne là et nous n'avons pas
forcément l'intention de de changer et
nous demandons bien sûr que le droit
commun puisse appliquer à Mayotte comme
tout dans les obsters nationales mais
cette histoire de fusion de l'article 74
73 n'est pas un sujet pour nous les
mains
quel sens justement donnez-vous au mot
aux notions différentielles le
responsabilité qu'elle contenue
attachéez-vous et où vous situeriez-vous
dans la limite de la notion d'autonomie
justement
nous on n'est pas dans la continuité de
nous on n'est pas forcément dans cette
nous on recherche pas forcément une
autonomie comme je le dis on était une
collectivité territoriale avec un peu
plus d'autonomie et on a prôné pour être
le dans le dans le droit commun donc
c'est discours d'autonomie c'est un
discours qui nous parle pas aux
marées et que nous ne cherchons pas du
tout du tout donc nous avoir encore une
fois quelques petites adaptations et
peut-être la possibilité juste de
pouvoir un peu plus discuter et négocier
avec les autres autorités de région mais
tout en étant pleinement dans le statut
actuel que les maorilles ont donc moi je
n'ose aller plus loin dans cette notion
d'autonomie parce que ce n'est pas du
tout une réalité de chez nous
et je ne peux pas me permettre de
développer ce sujet là parce que c'est
pas une réalité ce n'est pas une demande
ce n'est même pas
suggérable au maori
si l'article 73 de la Constitution
devait être modifiée
quel disposition souhaiteriez vous
modifié juste et lesquelles sont un
point de selon vous un point de blocage
pour des évolutions que vous
souhaiteriez
oui
moi comme je le dis je ne demande pas
forcément beaucoup de choses
sur la le statut de Mayotte si c'est
nous ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure la
possibilité un peu plus que peut-être la
Constitution doit permettre un peu plus
que certaines textes puissent être
adapté à nos réalités qui nous laisse un
peu plus d'ouverture
par rapport à la région c'est tout mais
je ne demande pas forcément une
modification profonde de ni de l'article
73 ni de l'article 74
estimez-vous que le statut européen de
région ultra périphérique pour être
fragilisé par une évolution des
compétences ou du pouvoir normatif de
Mayotte
non je
ne vois pas du tout en quoi ça peut ça
peut fragiliser je
les autres rues pour cela depuis très
longtemps et ils fonctionnent très bien
donc comme je le dis on ne cherche pas
forcément à changer beaucoup de dons
donc on reste dans le statut actuel
région collectivité unique et
périphérique il y a pas je ne vois pas
comment ça peut être fragilisé
la population adhère à la perspective
d'une éventuelle
évolution des institutions ou à une
extension des compétences une possible
révision constitutionnelle
suscite-t-elle des inquiétudes ou des
espoirs
impossible révision constitutionnelle
chez nous ce site plus d'inquiétude que
de
que d'espoir
s'inscrit pas du tout dans une
perspective d'évolution des institutions
voilà aujourd'hui comme je dis Mayotte
est bien dans le statut qu'il a qui l'a
choisi donc on ne s'inscrit pas du tout
dans une révision quelconque de la du
modification de statut attention je
parle pas des petites attentions de la
de la Constitution que être bien prise
mais
une évolution pleine de statut de
Mayotte ne peut pas
donc nous ce que nous demandons c'est
juste que Mayotte puisse aller au bout
de statut actuel qui a étudié a été
donné c'est-à-dire la productivité
unique à double compétences mais nous ne
demandons pas une évolution quelconque
du statut de Mayotte et les Maoris sont
inquiets quand ils entendent tout c'est
ce commentaire sur une possibilité de
l'article 73 73 et 74 bien sûr on se
pose la question dans tout ça ou alors
nous nous retrouvons
l'amendement qui avait été directement
tiré les travaux de Michel Magra qui est
présenté lors de l'examen d'une
proposition de loi constitutionnelle en
octobre 2020 au Sénat que pensez-vous de
sa rédaction
[Musique]
si vous n'avez pas eu le temps de le
regarder ce n'est pas très grave vous ne
pourrez nous faire une réponse écrite
c'est ce qu'on va faire
je n'ai pas eu
s'excuse il n'a pas pu participer
en présentiel parce qu'il est à Mayotte
et les nouvelles règles du Sénat
[Musique]
interdisent les visios pour pour les
sénateurs d'une manière générale pas
forcément
l'essayateurs de Mayotte et il avait une
question à vous poser qu'il m'a fait
parvenir donc sous la précédente
mandature le président
suit badine avait pris l'initiative pour
des propositions de clarification
institutionnelle afin précisément de
donner plein d'effets à l'aspect
régional monsieur Benissa housseni était
de la même majorité
que pense l'actuel président de ces
propositions de son prédécesseur
il y a il y a eu en fait c'est le terme
qui a été utilisé à l'époque qui
consistait à dire tous les tâches
institutionnels qui inquiétaient les
gens le terme de tous les temps
sectionnel même dans l'eau même si dans
le fond on estime que le travail qu'il
doit nous amener vers
[Musique]
une départementalisation et une
régionalisation en tout cas cette
collectivité unique pleine de plein
exercice doit être mise en place on a
considéré à l'époque que tout n'a pas
été forcément mis en place et
correctement mise en place pour nous
permettre d'exercer pleinement cette
compétence là et que pour cela il y
avait un travail d'adaptation de
réorganisation de notre statut d'une
manière générale qui était à être mis en
place
je crois que dans ces propositions là
qui ont été faites il y a sous le fond
c'était nécessaire mais peut-être que
c'était de la forme qui n'était pas
forcément
y compris
notamment le fait de changer la
dénomination de notre territoire qui
s'appelle département de Mayotte le
dénommé autrement peut effectivement
choqué et les gens justement s'inquiéter
parce que ils avaient peur que ça nous
amené vers d'autres statuts
institutionnels que le statut de
département de collectivité unique que
nous que nous connaissons aujourd'hui
les gens s'inquiétaient en disant que
peut-être c'était de retour en arrière
vers une collectivité
et sortir de l'article central 13 pour
aller sur la t74 il y avait cette
inquiétude là mais je crois que sur le
fond il y a un travail qui a mené pour
aller jusqu'au bout de cette
départementalisation et jusqu'au bout de
cette régionalisation de maillotine pour
moi sur le fond il y avait il y a un
travail à faire
je vous remercie pour ces propos très
éclairants je vais passer la parole à
mes collègues si elles ont une question
à vous poser
[Musique]
non elles n'ont pas de question parce
que vos propos ont été d'une grande
clarté ah madame Lopez je n'ai pas de
question je voulais simplement vous
remercier pour vous expliquer
vous dire que vraiment bon vous
explications ont été vraiment très
claires nous dire que vous ne voulez pas
changer grand chose qu'on vous laisse
simplement une plus grande liberté si je
comprends bien
pour appliquer les spécificités locales
ce que je pense qui est normal comme
dans les normes on se rend compte que
parfois
on vous impose des normes qui ne sont
pas du tout adaptés à votre territoire
et je crois que c'est et je crois que
c'est cela oui oui mais on avait déjà
fait des on a déjà fait des rapports sur
certains sujets certains domaines je
vais prendre ne serait-ce que par
exemple dans le BTP ou même en
agriculture et on vous impose des normes
qui ne sont pas du tout adaptées à votre
territoire
donc on a bien pris note que
effectivement c'est ce que vous
souhaitez plus de concertation et
surtout que l'on tienne compte de ce que
vous exprimez avec vos spécificités
locales et je pense que c'est tout à
fait normal et on va faire remonter cela
merci en tout cas je donne juste encore
un exemple madame dans ce que vous dites
sur la partie formation des élus ne
serait-ce que ça
le coût ici qui est calculé pour
permettre aux élus maori de se former
c'est le même principe de calcul que
j'ai lu parisien pour aller en formation
sauf que on n'en tient pas compte que à
Mayotte les élus les formations se font
à Paris et qu'ils ont des billets
d'avion prendre ils ont de l'hébergement
à prendre et que lorsque le Parisien lui
doit faire une formation ça lui fait
quelque part à faire que le métro à
prendre vous voyez ce sont ces choses-là
ou c'est le même loi qui est à Paris qui
s'applique chez nous à Mayotte sans te
dire compte que cela nous sommes
éloignants loin nous sommes ce sont ces
petites choses là qui méritent
aujourd'hui d'être revu d'être adapté
voilà
oui oui très bientôt on l'a bien compris
donc merci de d'insister sur ce point-là
qui est très important merci
merci à vous
alors passe la parole madame Marie merci
j'ai été trop bonjour monsieur le
Président j'ai été troublé par le fait
que Air France ne desserve pas Mayotte
est-ce que Air France a des servi
Mayotte autrefois et sinon à partir de
quand Air France n'a plus desservie
Mayotte madame
et nous sommes le seul territoire de la
République qui n'est pas desservie par
Air France
malgré les demandes assistantes que nous
mettons en place
est-ce qu'il y a un problème
d'infrastructure par exemple de pistes
je ne connais pas je vous pose la
question on a des pistes mais à France
et tout à tout à fait en fait c'est lié
au début quand Air Austral a été créé et
austral à l'époque était une filiale de
Air France donc Air France avait fait le
choix d'aller jusqu'à la Réunion
à Mayotte entre-temps Air Austral a été
complètement vendue par
r austral par Air France et du coup et
France nous continuons à nous pas de
servir qu'ils ont tout à fait d'appareil
capable
d'aller à Mayotte mais c'est n'est
jamais ça n'a jamais été intégré dans la
stratégie de France que de se servir
Mayotte
malgré le problème de chez nous nous
avons énormément de problèmes de désert
sur le territoire ça soit en matière de
fraise ou en matière de tout simplement
de personnes aujourd'hui Mayotte se
retrouve très enclavé avec Air Austral
tout seul qui fait la ligne donc pas de
concurrence donc des prix exorbitants du
billet du billet d'avion pour aller à
Mayotte et la solution pour nous c'est
Air France qui doit aller aussi un
maillot
s'il y a pas d'autres questions je vous
je vous remercie pour toutes ces
explications et puis nous en avons bien
pris note nous vous proposons aussi de
nous renvoyer le questionnaire avec plus
de détails
si vous l'estimez
utile et nous vous souhaitons une
excellente fin de journée
Merci à VOUS bonne journée à vous madame
merci au revoir